Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
[Azione chiama, genera,
crea, ispira azione]
[Il conto alla rovescia
non lascia scampo]
[Possiamo fermare
il cambiamento climatico]
Io sono Margot Gomis, e ho 19 anni.
E mi chiedo per quale motivo sia qui oggi.
Forse ve lo state chiedendo anche voi.
Come ho detto, sono
una ragazza di 19 anni;
ed è vero che da quando Greta Thumberg
ha fatto parlare di sé tutto il mondo,
va un po' di moda
dare la parola a noi giovani
sui temi del cambiamento climatico.
E poter avere la parola,
in un paese in cui ci è data
molto raramente,
è molto importante:
ma lo è ancora di più poter parlare
e affrontare queste tematiche insieme.
Oggi vi racconto come lo faccio io.
E per questo, dovete conoscere
come è nato il mio interesse
e la mia passione per la natura.
Tutto è nato attraverso
il dono della vista.
Io sono cresciuta con entrambi
i genitori non vedenti,
e questo ha condizionato molto
la mia infanzia.
Quando ero piccola, mia madre
mi chiedeva di descriverle i paesaggi,
durante le nostre passeggiate in montagna
o i nostri viaggi in treno.
Che erano molto frequenti,
perché io abitavo in Francia
e spesso facevamo
la tratta Chambéry - Milano.
Quindi avevo la possibilità di notare
come il paesaggio cambiasse
tra una stagione e l'altra.
Il mese che mi colpiva di più era maggio,
perché era possibile vedere
infinite sfumature di verde,
pochi alberi con ancora i fiori
e le montagne ancora bianche.
Ogni volta volevo che, per mia mamma,
le descrizioni fossero sempre più precise.
Quindi faceva regalare
vari libri per bambini
sulle piante, sugli animali;
e quindi è così che è nato
il mio amore per la natura.
Col tempo, crescendo, ho sentito parlare
di riscaldamento globale
e cambiamento climatico;
ma non pensavo fossero problemi
che mi riguardassero:
pensavo fossero problemi
che dovessero gestire gli adulti,
e non noi ragazzi.
Nonostante ciò, facevo
la mia raccolta differenziata;
sgridavo i miei compagni,
quando non le facevano;
cercavo di non sprecare acqua,
o di non mangiare carne
che fosse allevata in un certo modo.
Ma non ho mai cercato di impegnarmi
per affrontare concretamente
questo problema,
perché, proprio come ho detto,
pensavo che non fosse un mio dovere.
Tutto è cambiato
quando il mio professore di scienze
mi ha iscritto a un progetto:
"B-Corp school".
Mi ha spiegato che questi progetti,
creati apposta per le scuole,
permettono a noi studenti
di entrare in contatto
con il mondo della sostenibilità,
cercando di creare delle start-up
che partono da una
problematica ambientale.
Eravamo divisi in dieci gruppi,
e il mio doveva occuparsi
dell'inquinamento
nell'ambito della mobilità personale.
E quando si tratta di mettersi in gioco,
io non sono per niente timida;
quindi, appena arrivata,
mi sono messa a fare ricerca, a lavorare.
Quindi i miei compagni di gruppo
mi hanno scelto subito come speaker,
e il mio compito era quello
di esporre la problematica,
e come pensavamo di affrontarla.
Il mio team realizzò "RENTECO"
un sito che permetteva
di noleggiare ai viaggiatori
veicoli sostenibili,
attraverso un'applicazione
con un sistema di geolocalizzazione.
E finita l'esperienza col mezzo,
di vedere quanta CO2 e altri gas serra
hanno evitato di emettere,
rispetto a un veicolo tradizionale.
Quindi, lo scopo di questa start-up
era quello di far nascere nel cliente
quasi una coscienza ecologica,
di fargli capire quanto era importante
e quanto era determinante l'inquinamento
nell'ambito della mobilità personale.
Nonostante la mia start-up
non abbia vinto,
ho avuto la possibilità di conoscere
e approfondire i miei rapporti
con gli organizzatori di questo evento,
e soprattutto di realizzare
che avevo le capacità
di impegnarmi concretamente
in questa lotta contro l'inquinamento.
In seguito sono stata invitata
ad altri 20 "B-Corp School" e B-Corp,
i quali hanno il compito
e vogliono far capire alle persone
che oltre al profitto è molto importante
creare un'atmosfera positiva
per i lavoratori,
e rispettare l'ambiente che ci circonda.
Al momento di preparare il discorso,
non sapevo che cosa dire,
data la mia giovane età
e la mia ignoranza
su alcuni temi ambientali.
Poi ho capito che potevo donare
la mia esperienza.
Quindi quello che avevo realizzato,
nel momento in cui sono passata
da una vita passiva
ad una attiva e d'impegno.
Quindi il messaggio
che ho voluto lasciare,
e che voglio lasciare oggi,
è che noi giovani possiamo e dobbiamo
essere parte di questo cambiamento.
Ma non solo attraverso proteste,
che servono solo
per sensibilizzare le persone;
ma anche attraverso azioni concrete.
Cambiando le nostre abitudini,
essendo da esempio per i nostri genitori
e le persone che ci circondano;
organizzando eventi con le scuole,
le quali rappresentano
la base dell'educazione.
Quindi, da lì iniziare a insegnare
che cos'è la sostenibilità
e come rispettare
l'ambiente che ci circonda.
Noi giovani siamo creativi,
abbiamo le capacità,
non abbiamo paura
della novità e del diverso;
ma proprio perché, dato
che stiamo ancora crescendo,
ci abituiamo più facilmente
a un cambiamento.
E questo è dimostrato dal fatto
che noi giovani siamo
i protagonisti di molte lotte,
non solo contro l'inquinamento
ma anche contro
le discriminazioni razziali,
di genere e di orientamento sessuale.
Qua si tratta del nostro futuro,
e di come vogliamo che sia.
L'essere umano ha fatto di tutto
per migliorare la sua qualità di vita:
costruendo case, inventando macchinari
e circondandosi
di tutti i comfort possibili.
Ma io oggi non sono qui
per giudicare questo.
E ovviamente mi riferisco alle persone
che tutti i giorni non affrontano
problematiche come la fame e la povertà.
Questo progresso è stato possibile
grazie alle rivoluzioni
scientifiche, industriali, tecnologiche,
che però non hanno tenuto conto
dell'impatto che avrebbe avuto
questo cambiamento irresponsabile
sull'ambiente.
Quindi, il progresso
fine a se stesso non è positivo.
Il progresso deve portare l'uomo
a vivere in armonia
con la natura che lo circonda.
Perciò tocca a noi giovani
e adulti, tutti insieme,
far sì che ci sia una nuova
Rivoluzione Scientifica,
una nuova Rivoluzione Industriale
che siano orientate
verso la sostenibilità.
Io sono una studentessa
di Scienze Ambientali
presso l'Università La Sapienza a Roma,
e ho deciso di intraprendere
questo percorso formativo
perché voglio essere concretamente
parte di questa rivoluzione.
Per finire, tocca a noi, giovani, adulti,
e noi che rappresentiamo
e supportiamo questo cambiamento,
far capire alle persone
di tutte le generazioni
che vale la pena cambiare vita.
E con ciò intendo: basta al consumismo,
all'egoismo, alla mancanza di rispetto,
per noi, per gli altri,
e per il pianeta in cui viviamo.
Noi dobbiamo essere
energia pura per la Terra,
dobbiamo ricordare che l'essere umano
è sempre stato, e sempre sarà,
parte della natura;
che la sua casa è il pianeta in cui vive,
e che la sua famiglia
sono gli altri esseri viventi.
Io sono Margot Gomis, ho 19 anni,
e sono qui perché rappresento
il futuro di questo pianeta.
E perciò ho il diritto,
e il dovere, di difenderlo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)